now you need to have where both of you
are feeling adequate in what each
other's doing in other words you don't
feel like there's a need to
push right it doesn't feel as if there's
a need to hold
on is everybody sort you don't have to
be all with me but you know what I mean
so how so we're going to start again so
he's going to attack you going to be
doing this so this is why you have
to okay so now what happened there was
you have to sort of think about his
posture am am I sound am I safe so so
this is still Technical and I'm glad
we've got two seniors really because
what chance of we've got lower grades if
two seniors so I'm try so today is going
to be about how we're going to take away
this doing of technical I sensey you
didn't see too much technical L on today
but because we've been programmed to do
technical right so this
little this little thing here
pushing see that soft
wall or
hard so I need you to do it again I need
you to tell me
what so you're going to push
in is it hard wall or soft wall hard
hard okay that
suspension yes but but if the arm
moves then this is
technical if you don't have to move
anything I don't have to move anything
then it means that I've given the person
space I've given I've allowed the person
to be their self in other words please
go past I'm not going to in impend you
is that the word so as he comes here if
I come here please go past in his gut
feeling he sort of says yeah you're
saying that but I actually feel like
you're a bit too close to me see now
that you push in there a hard
one so when I
move it's it's raising ahead a bit but
when I move pushing
see it's s the
wall softer isn't
it so I don't measure where I move to he
measures it for
me I mean if you get it today God do
you're doing well I want to unload what
I've had for 20 years in in
me if we get I'll use R again a strong
man he's going to
do right so he takes it down as strong
as you can strong as you can see to
me is
nothing not being rude to him but see
you can see look you can see his hands
white but I don't feel
that something happened to me but it
didn't happen by me getting better
technique it happened to me by
thinking outside the box thinking in a
different
dimension so so because we're all
getting older our and I want to do once
only give it to you today if you pick
any of it up you'll start searching it
yourself that's the main thing you know
you'll start searching yourself so don't
worry about doing it technical because
you are as he comes you know you you
will be te see how light that is
see how soft that is still if I want if
I I don't want to lose this I don't want
to lose this it becomes a hard W so you
need you'll need to talk to each other a
little bit about whether it's hard or
soft does anybody have any questions at
this
stage when you first did
that when you first did that come on by
right there was actually a gap I think
saw in my eyes
between um UK and Tori you know that
there was no touching there was a
gap but but all the time that you've
been doing it now you've made sure
there's a sort of
a yes because I S only because I moved
on what I was saying is please go past
is the is the
theory and then you go more subtle and
you do a measurement so the please go
past is he doesn't feel restricted in
any way but if he was to push into me'
go I can't move into that but it's not
hard it's
soft is there if I done if I done this
Gap yeah then i' I'd be sort a little
bit stupid thinking I was Superman if I
was going to hold him off this far
because he'll gain momentum but if I can
just stroke his his gear if you like
when he pushes
in but what I'm also doing I'm not going
s my
mess you hold him there don't don't fail
you see there's a lot of if you like
humbling there's a lot of humbling to
the art so when you hum when you when
you genuinely mean please go
past the reward when I said I've reached
my goal in iido it's because the
joy this sounds a bit heavy game but
when he comes the joy of movement with
another person I mean Peter know this
he's do he does Bor and dancing the joy
of being with another partner is enough
to satisfy me so I don't need the
technique bit heavy going is it but you
see what I'm trying to say you all want
to get to sens you I hope you do any you
won't get to sens You by just doing
technique alone you're going to have to
work you've all got intuition you've all
got gut feeling you know you can forget
about the spiritual stuff and that I
that I personally follow I've worked it
out that all you need to do is stop
trying to
win stop trying to be nagay and say this
is my technique you know you
show got you the next
um so you're going to try and do that if
you've worked out what I'm saying the
next thing that I noticed when I watched
Ray was watch my watch my face I watched
his eyes go up and follow John's hand
down see that's
technical so I'm not saying don't go
there yet but when he comes it's the
it's the movement of oh you know just
the movement is enough to fulfill
me right so I think enough I think
um I don't know if this angle's right
hang on don't that angle's right so
you're going to go through that
hopefully because you're going to be
criticizing you don't know if you're in
the right place or
not if you get this what I call Miracle
thing happen you'll move anyhow wherever
you need to
be wouldn't be a bad thing
we test each other with this s yes
that's what I'm saying you lose your
balance is that a good thing what I need
you to do is I need you to oh sensy give
us iido to destroy our self and then
when we've destroyed ourself in other
words when we've stopped being yeah I
like that enjoy you know when we become
the humble person that you should be the
technique will take care of itself if
you're in will fight
hopefully um but you as a person to
fulfill your journey in
life you want to end up hopefully in a
peaceful place than when we started out
or or what's being bombarded as a
reborn way it it it's
being yeah it's being happy with
yourself you what I mean it's being it's
being happy with your life um but you
you do have to do the tech home